[music playing]
Neil, Theo, congratulations.
You've made it into the
finale for this competition.
It's only one thing
you have left to do,
and that is to go
back home and recreate
an iconic weapon from
history, the Tai Chi sword.
Emerging from China
over 2,500 years ago,
the Tai Chi sword is
known as the gentleman
of weapons due to its
refinement and sophistication.
Symbolizing power and
authority, the weapon
is one of the most common
ancient weapons still
in practice with millions of
students studying it worldwide.
Fast and light, it's
straight, double-edged blade
was used for quick
stabs and lethal cuts.
While the sword's fairly
blunt lower section was built
to block and deflect attacks.
Its reputation is also
preserved in popular culture
through its role as
the coveted Green
Destiny Sword in
the film "Crouching
Tiger, Hidden Dragon".
Your blade must be double
edged, have a winged guard,
and pommel.
Last time I was on the
show, I made an naginata.
In comparison, the Tai Chi
sword has a lot more blade.
It's going to be a lot of work.
You will have five
days at your home
forge to accomplish this.
At the end of five days, you'll
return to present your work
to our panel of expert judges.
And only after they've
brutally tested
them will they
declare one of you
the "Forged of Fire"
Champion of Champions
and give you that cash.
I'm concerned because the
Tai Chi sword is really light.
I probably have
regular knives that are
heavier than that whole sword.
So that's a challenge for me.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Good luck, man.
My name is Neil Kamimura.
I was asked to come back,
and I would never say no
to my "Forged in Fire" family.
What I feel I've
come back for is
to represent the people
just starting off
and show them that
you can do this.
I've got to build
a Tai Chi sword.
This is the first time I've
ever made something this long.
Holy [bleep].
But I'm never going to quit.
The blade has to
be heated evenly.
Trying to get the sword lighter
has been kind of difficult.
And being that
this is the longest
thing I've ever heat treated,
I'm not really set up for it.
You can feel it
want to bend because
of the weight of the tip.
So I am scared.
If something goes wrong, I
won't have time to fix it.
My blade is straight.
I don't have to re-quench it.
I'm stoked.
My name is Theo Nazz.
Winning "Forged in
Fire" allowed me
to turn my hobby into a
full time career in knife
making and teaching.
The biggest obstacle
is the raw amount
of forging I have to do then
getting the guard to forge well
to the blade itself and
then being able to forge
the pommel on as well.
If the welds don't
hold, everything
will be coming apart.
How important are
guards on swords?
They can be integral.
Ba dum tic.
The quench, big moment of truth.
If things go wrong right
now, I've got to start again.
So no pressure.
Perfectly straight.
Things went amazingly well.
I'm happy with the blade.
If I win, the money would
most likely go to starting
a new life with my wife.
I had to put that in there.
I'd get in trouble if I didn't.
Oh, God.
We're still recording.
I'm sorry, Daisy.
Theo, Neil, welcome
back to the forge.
Theo, tell us about your blade.
It went very well.
I did an integral
guard and pummel.
I forged welding
on both of them.
The blade's handle
is relatively simple
construction so that it can
be beaten the [bleep] out of.
You sound monotonically
excited about that.
Neil, how did it
go for you, man?
Same recipe as the
last time I was here.
Go to the junkyard, get
some stuff because I didn't
expect to make it this far.
All right.
Well, gentlemen, up first
is the strength test.
Ben.
Champions, I'm going to be
hitting this bamboo five times.
Remember, it's not what your
sword does to the bamboo
but what the bamboo
does to your sword.
Theo, you're up first.
How are you feeling?
A little nervous.
Let's go for it.
[music playing]
Well, Theo, this is
a brute of a sword.
The edge held up perfectly.
I don't see any problems.
Still straight as an arrow.
The handle is a little bit
difficult to really control.
I would have liked a
little bit more meat on it.
But very well done.
Thank you.
Neil, you're up next.
Boy, that's a tough test.
That bamboo setup,
it's literally
just blunt force trauma.
I don't think a lot of
blades can survive that kind
of jarring and punishment.
[music playing]
Well, Neil, this
sword is heavy.
I wouldn't want to be
running around with it.
There's a little bit of
damage that the bamboo
gave back to your sword.
But it's still straight.
Very well done.
Nice job.
Thank you.
Next up is the sharpness test.
For that, Dave.
All right, gentlemen.
I'm going to be chopping
through these tatami mats
using both edges of your sword.
Let's see if your blades
still have an edge.
Neil, you're up first.
Are you ready for it?
Yeah.
Sure.
I'm very nervous at this point.
This is the make it
or break it moment.
I have to perform
well on this test.
All right, Theo.
Definitely a sharp blade.
You can see the nice
clean slice and then
burying into the second.
I like the design.
It's definitely a solid piece.
And that's one of the
nice things about it.
I don't feel like it's
going to go anywhere.
Well done.
Thank you.
All right, Neil.
You ready?
Yeah.
[laughs]
[music playing]
So the biggest thing
is all that weight.
About twice what it needs
to be as far as weight goes.
It's difficult to swing.
And then the edge
of this blade, it's
got a very stout profile
almost like an ax.
Just kept it from cutting
all the way through.
Theo, Neil, we
took five champions,
we whittled it down to two.
But there can only
be one "Forged
in Fire" Champion of Champions.
That champion is Theo.
Congratulations.
Neil, unfortunately, your
weapon did not make the cut.
Neil, you came
up and showed us
that you had the heart
to make it to the finals
against four other champions.
But your sword took some damage
through the strength test.
But more than that, it's heavy.
A Tai Chi sword is known to
be strong, sharp, and light.
For those reasons, we
have to let you go.
Neil, please
surrender your weapon.
I 100% agree with the judges.
Theo earned it.
But I don't look at this
as a failure in any means.
Because I gave it my all.
I can walk away look
everybody in the eye
and have everyone's respect.
And that's worth more
to me than any title
or any amount of money.
Theo, congratulations.
You are the new "Forged in
Fire" Champion of Champions
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
How do you feel right now?
Woo, the nerves and the
butterflies and the nerves
are still going.
But thank you, guys.
Please present your
weapon to the judges.
I [bleep] won.
My ego was pretty
big beforehand,
and I think this is only
going to inflate it.
Not a good thing,
not a bad thing.
I think.